when we saw the Spurs your soul and your
personality are put into the box there
will be a new king
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
your grace you want to do see me
yes
I like to pretend there is legs
you see lower houses there the hens and
I and the Fox that snatches their little
babies and you collected so many so much
talent almost too much bostonia there's
no such thing is too much and the one
thing Lord pop would have never lost
control of this house Spurs of the East
lucky for you there's one last road trip
before the tournament starts I suggest
you find a way to get on nights on the
same page or else you would never this
city loves me like they love the king in
the fourth get it done
[Music]
unbelievable got share attempt the
rotation guys we missed the hero's last
year
if you're feeling cramps expand your
mind Squyres these days so entitled
they'll stop calling ask wise Markuson
you don't scare me Terry you think
there's some wise federal boys that I've
seen that before
that bears a soul bucks when you saw him
with House Spurs your soul and
personality go into the box so it's like
a Spurs culture thing I didn't want it
to come to this but there's too much
talent here in this room for us to be
treading water in the fourth seat the
sole box will help us contain our
emotions and our egos so that this group
can reach its potential
also make sure dough is dirt that
thing's the reason nobody heard of me in
San Antonio yeah that's the reason hole
do it all right out I want you to close
your eyes and place your hand on the box
sir ah Horford do you hereby commit
fully sacrifice your soul for a good of
house Celtx
[Music]
so did it work or why they didn't flinch
all right who's next
anyone I'll do it okay no lucky give me
that box I'll do it Thanks this is for
Knights Marcus the smart I I can I'm
sorry my whole game is about emotion
jaelyn
oh I'm just worried about my brand is
all what about you Kyrie subjugate the
light of my soul to your rectangular
prism no way
I can't even commit to next year Wow
what a leader okay then why don't you do
it well I just don't want to jeopardize
my mama mentality is off yeah god forbid
you stop shooting 20-footers oh please
you're one to talk
you know what clearly this was a bad
idea okay you guys are obviously not the
Spurs and I am clearly not Lord pop no
you know
you're Brad Stevens best X's nose man
I've ever known
yeah nobody came right out of timeout
plays like you yeah well unfortunately
there's no timeout long enough for me to
fix all of this team's issues who over
there was who said that the time long
wait time lord I thought that was just a
nickname
there are things people don't know about
me don't get enough minutes tell me
about it
but I'm pretty versatile can rebound
like a block like a stop time where'd
you learn how to do that Texas A&M but
you were only there for two years
well was I so how does one just stopped
I'm just asking questions here it's a
magic potion I'm called
sudah it's banned in the realm since
Jason Kidd used it against House Lakers
late in a battle when your no timeouts
left exactly how long are we talking
about here that will last a leader
you've come up with the way to solve our
problems
34 years whichever comes first why 34
the truth 34 is the truth number guys
worst and Wayne way actually no that's
just how much soda I have all right
you've got this little commander yeah
you're Brad Stevens now you can do this
little commander are you all mad do you
really think he could just come up with
something magical out of timeout play
that gonna fix all of our chemistry it's
juice yeah you know what I do because
I'm Brad and Steven
Time Lord ready when you are right whoa
commander you look like you've aged 34
years yep so you you did in nope so
what's all that mostly just gibberish
gave up 20 years ago actually what's
that all right I've got some good news
and some bad news bad news first lucky
that frozen in time with me
the soda spilled on him unfortunately
for lucky he swore a blood oath to
always perform during timeouts obviously
never thinking he will yeah but he kept
performing he was juggling and dancing
doing those wacky dunks man was he funny
by year two he was mostly performing
stuff that could be done from a chair
like balancing bowls singing whatever it
was around year three where he stopped
talking
he was just my men and deliriously
flailing his arms by year four I thought
he was doing this long bit where he
would just play dead by year five I
realized it wasn't a bit so what's the
good news
well I came up with a few pretty clever
inbound clays that might get us to the
second round
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and so if you subscribe to bleach report
you can get notified anytime a new game
of zones comes out and can I comment
first yes anything even though I'm
clearly not the first comment so
whatever you want as long as you follow
the Community Guidelines stop stop he
saw us he saw subscribing